here's the biggest problem [ __ ]
entrepreneurs cry about the way they
want it to be instead of reacting to the
way it actually is mommy doesn't come
around nice like a visible ask you with
clarity hi my name is Gabby Thomas I've
been telling you
accounts of equity I'll triple a given a
pedigree Savina no pleasure my faculties
are putting the work that I'm doing are
the moving furniture heaven if somebody
wanted to look right yeah there is a
little value oh yeah okay they need to
get $150,000 a year time don't get a
twist man stop your hand real quick most
people that get money from Silicon
Valley don't come from [ __ ] Silicon
Valley so stop it right there but I'm
not letting you just can shake it
because I [ __ ] she's not true move
[ __ ] Denver [ __ ] [ __ ] you soon
because that's a career law why do I
think Texas with all my heart because I
yeah I'll tell you exactly right here
think I hate Texas I listen I hate to
send more than you [ __ ] hate the
system right now because I built the
wine business where I ship wine and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] offense they to expects
money the politicians and blossom only
one store from shipping the Texas me
because I was at the top of the heap I
was doing four million in sales here
saving all Texas people money because I
was creating competition and the
wholesalers three of them paid your
[ __ ] [ __ ] ask Houston politicians
to block me from shipping here and one
day I got a letter and said you can't
ship here anymore
so what am I supposed to do I can open a
store in [ __ ] Texas
and throw down or I care just that's
what you have to do nobody gives a [ __ ]
about your feelings bro come on
so no for real like click and the leader
I'm coming at you like this is on post
when you you're a kid like don't cry
about their biggest problems
[ __ ] entrepreneurs cry about the way
they want it to be instead of reacting
to the way it action is so you need to
eliminate rich kids because I was born
with pick I live in a studio apartment
with eight family members on the sides
of the stage and split toilet paper okay
so there's no excuse of some most people
on a born with love brows they lose
because they're soft so if you're so
angry put it's a good energy and go with
the denver work enjoy nineteen this
morning to chill then move to dinner or
wait for laws to change you can't cry
about how it is that ships never ever
ever ever the right move sunday
afternoon
the land for Vancouver like 757 [ __ ]
email to the pain felt great
let's go home and watch a little
basketball Skeletor we
I really have to put the office filmer
and contest
then we're money this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is a special
edition of the askgaryvee show for
Michigan one they're missing 16 Ross is
happy and be away on family vacation
we've got a gun episode tomorrow
then we'll go dark-sided uh you know
maybe I'll sneak in an iPhone one here
never be with Jordan working out polish
makes them in but mental last we'll see
okay like I mean what are going to talk
about it and then [ __ ] sit on assets
when they go down thirty to fifty
percent Oh absolute pretty much tell
everything on that's how you do it okay
okay I sold my try so my side called my
Twitter stock when I thought it wasn't
going to be as valuable and I was right
that was a good idea yeah in the
kitchens every second birthday
oh my joy if they had a message they
won't on my side be be running through
that money I just told my no I don't
like no time no I don't want no time no
time no time see me running